all right rose
rose froze where'd you grow up where are
you from i'm born and raised right here
downtown l.a
let's get right on ski grill wow and uh
tell me about your family then
uh this is an interesting story my mom
is from cuba my dad is
from belize but we was born and raised
down here i have
six siblings brothers and sisters my mom
had four girls and two boys
my mom died when i was 16 years old my
dad odin in front of me when i was eight
and i've never been out outside of
downtown l.a i've always
been here because this is the only place
that i know
i started using drugs when i was eight
years old
and i'm 42 years old now so i've been on
it for 40
almost 40 something years and i just
decided to get clean
like about two months ago because i feel
like that's not the life of me and i
have nine kids
i have five girls and four boys and
i gave custody up to my kids dad because
i didn't want to put them through what i
went through out here
i know what this life is like i thank
god that i've never been raped
or beaten but because i've been homeless
out hear all the time
i live in a tent on the next street on
alaka
and i've been homeless for 42 years i've
been taking care of my own self
at the age of 10 years old i had my own
appointment
except by selling dope that's all i
really i know how to do is cook dope i
became the best cooker downtown l.a
so quite naturally everybody wanted me
because a lot of people's don't know how
to make dough
well now since google show you how to do
it but
i just feel like it's something that
keeps me down here
i think that's because i lost my mom and
dad down here and when i go anywhere
else i don't feel them around me
it feels like home yeah i feel like this
is at home if i leave
if i leave anywhere and i don't see the
time the downtown buildings i get
paranoid
and anybody that's you know i'm in the
car with have to bring me back
because these are the only streets that
my mom and dad walk
when i was a little girl and this is the
only place i know all my brothers and
sisters
moved like all my sisters live in
bakersfield my brothers
live in inglewood but i choose to stay
downtown l.a and i don't know why
how far did you go in school i made it
to the ninth grade i was a freshman
i had i had a learning disability like i
don't read and spell good
but i'm learning and i just remain
teachable
i know every day is a learning
experience for me
and one thing i appreciate my mom and
dad is they taught me how to take care
of myself at such a young age
due to the fact that they all they done
my dad was a long shark
my mom all they did is do drugs so we
had to learn to take care of ourselves
we had to learn to cook for ourselves
i had to learn to take a shower for
ourselves because they was
on drugs and she didn't have time to do
that and i want me
that's why i choose to give my kids up
because i want a better life for them i
don't want them to have to go through
what i've been through
what was your favorite memory as a kid
my memory as a kid is my mom and dad
walking us around these streets
going up and down these streets and i
think the same route
is when i was a little girl and it was a
coincidence i don't i think it's a
blessing is my dad died in the
alexandria hotel which is one of the
most famous
hotels down here and now that's where my
mail goes
i've been back since the age 8 years old
to now
42 years later i'm back in the same
hotel i'm right down the hall from where
we live when so you're in a hotel you're
on a team i'm not here but
my friend i take showers and all my mail
go over there
so i go over there i'm able to go in and
take a shower
warm up and come back out but you've
been living in a tent for how long
i've been living in my tent for now
almost 25 years
can you live in a yeah i live in a tent
no can can you live in a
a house or an apartment or yeah if i had
them they don't i don't receive no gr
no nothing because how do you support
yourself now right now i
just got a job working at the medical
center across the street
and that's how i've been supporting
myself doing daddy and selling drugs
you've been selling drugs up until when
just recently just recently i just
stopped two months ago when i got my job
right here across the street
what what motivated you to change your
life around tired of going to jail
i'm tired of going to jail people say
they got your back but they don't
and i realized that i was a fool because
i'm out here
selling drugs for other people and i
when i go to jail
nobody puts money on my books but
there's probably something deeper than
tired of going to jail that that's
behind me you got to be sick and tired
of being sick and tired i'm tired of
i know where it takes me and i know this
life
and i know that if i don't stop you see
it's only two things
jails institutions are deaf and i don't
want either one of those
i want to be something in this life i
want to i want my kids to have something
in this life i don't want them
to have their mom die as a junkie
like my mom did who introduced you to
drugs at eight years old
all the people that i was around my mom
and dad i picked it up from my mom
i used to watch how they do it and one
day she put it down and she went to the
store and when she came back i picked it
up that was correct
crack cocaine that was back in the 80s
when it was real crack
now i don't know what it is but that's
what made me motivate me to change my
life
because i want something better
i always i always have elected to work
and have a job because i always like to
have my own
i don't like to get something out to
borrow something i ask people for
something
and then they throw it up to your face
i i believe the best way is to be
independent
and learn from my mistakes i live and i
learn
that's why i like little wang song he
said he a rookie in a vet
but he still remained teachable so what
do you think the difference is between
you
and everyone else here on skid row who
just seems content to stay here forever
my thing i think the difference is is
everybody have choices
and it's up to us what we make and what
we want
i believe that they struggle in the
fence right now they battle
battling with good and evil and
the devil is the devil is powerful like
jesus is powerful
but only if we let him win and if you
want to do better
you're gonna you're gonna do better i
think what keeps them down here
is that they lose their morals and their
values they forget
the way their parents raise them they
lose all home bases and when they come
out here
they get adapted to the new rules the
street rules
which is the wrong rules because the
streets don't love nobody
yeah but the street life seems to be
very addictive for a lot of people it's
very addictive because of the drugs
and the weak souls that's out here
because it's it's very powerful
but you we all have a choice to what we
want to make with our lives
sometimes you gotta some people gotta
hit rock bottom and some people just
know when it's time to let it go
and me i wanna live and to live down
here
i have to be clean and sober if not i'm
going to be walking around like these
crazy women bow feed it
with no clothes on running up and down
the street talking to myself
and i always pray to god that i never be
like that and i thank god that i haven't
yet
what what's been your lowest point
me choosing this life the the skid row
life over my kids
that's my lois i'm willing i was willing
to give my kids up
so that i can be out here on drugs
that's the noise
what do you think most people that don't
do drugs don't understand about
addiction is the word could take you
and the things that they come in but
it's not a conscious choice these people
make
knows it's something that's happening
it's like
it's like having a gorilla on your
shoulder and you're fighting
and you're fighting but he's holding on
that's what it's like it's hard
you're friends no have you ever had
friends
nope i don't believe in friends
friends is backstabbers the only friends
is my family
that's the only friends i need and my
kids
you've been about you ever been loved in
love yeah
i was with my kids there for 28 years
nine kids
by the same man and i went to prison for
selling drugs when i got out he cheated
on me
and that's why i've been out here ever
since i just
choose to do my own thing but i choose
not to let nobody get close to me
because people's they hear the flesh is
it was money made for sans
and i have trust issues because i give
people the benefit of the doubt
and this what i think they gonna do is
what they try to do but i already be
prepared for it
so i believe if you stay ready you don't
have to get ready
what's the most important lesson you've
learned in all your years
how to not do nothing to others that i
don't want done to me
treat people the way i want to be
treated
it's like the concept empathy the
ability to imagine how others feel
and in order to progress your empathetic
skills you must ask yourself how would
you feel
under the same circumstances that's what
i think so with all your time down here
living on the streets
what what qualities do you think you've
developed that
most people don't have the street life
is very difficult how to love myself
that i can't love others unless i love
myself
because i can tell everybody i love you
but do i love me
if i don't love me how can i love
someone else
and how to be loyal because
i don't do nothing to them what they do
to me and they have done a lot of things
to me
and what i do i pray for them and i ask
god
to help them and to forgive them because
they know not what they do
what has helped you helped me
the ability to love yourself to me
is being able to accept my world to
being able to realize that i'm my worst
enemy
that no one can do nothing to me unless
i allow them to
to be able to wake up and make a choice
am i just going to sit on the ground and
be obama
am i going to go out and look for a job
am i just going to sit here and get
drunk and get high
and say poor me poor me am i going to do
something about my life to make it
better
that's what i believe it is
you didn't imagine what your life would
have been like if you had
two parents that raised you and stuck
together and didn't yeah i probably
wouldn't never did drugs
i i well i really don't regret it
because i learned from all of it the
only thing i just miss
my mom and dad but i know they're my
guardian angels and stay with me
and that they would want to see me doing
better than what i've been doing and so
that's my goal
is to do better for myself
for my kids all right rose thank you so
much for sharing your story
thank you so much for your best of luck
thank you god bless you
so what do you think finally a positive
story
i know you got it i got so many dark
ones my god
you